Hunter how is financing for your five
films evolved from the first one to know
okay first up for my first film two
miles per hour we financed it in large
part with credit cards both Josh and I
said we can't find any sponsors we don't
know where the money's at put a lot of
work into that but a lot of energy into
trying to get you know other people to
help fund the film and really blanked
out so we just took our credit cards and
financed it and we got to a point in the
process where we needed to tap in a
little bit of our retirement savings
which was nice that I had that available
cuz I noticed you know some people don't
and and it's interesting because people
are always so afraid to spend their
retirement but I found that really a
freeing activity like ultimately it's
been a great way to use that investment
ultimately further my life and my
experiences which I think should be the
right thing so that was ten miles per
hour we it was tough we took a lot of
our own you know money and just dumped
it in and said we got to get this thing
done and we've got to make it and and uh
and put it out to the market eventually
over the course of time with ten miles
per hour
the money that we did hard cash that we
actually spent on our credit cards and
retirement was was returned to us so
that was that was cool
all the sweat they probably never
totally got paid back but it's nice to
know that the film is still generating
some revenue almost you know eight years
or so after its release so it's pretty
cool
second film ten yards we were actually
at this point in time able to start
looking at some sponsorships and we were
able to close some sponsorships but it
was pretty limited I mean we were
talking fifteen to twenty thousand
dollars somewhere in that range or cash
that we raised but it took quite a bit
of edge off with making the film by this
time we had some of the camera equipment
already you know we'd invested some of
that early money and to sort of building
a program there was also some additional
cash that was put in as sort of an
investment from from an individual and
so that was again we were in a place
where all of a sudden there was a little
bit of money but we didn't quite have
enough money
to really round it out get the film done
and then have enough left over for a
launch so we were you know burning all
of the cash on production which is
probably the biggest challenge I think
filmmakers face is we get a little bit
of money some somehow or another you
know and we blow it all to make this
film and then you're in this situation
where maybe the film's made a lot of
times people blow it all before they
edit it you know and then that's a
really difficult position to be in so I
think you know you really got to think
that through and divvy it up and let
people know early off that it's going to
be a long time before they probably see
money so with 10 yards unfortunately
because we were putting all of all of
the money that we we received from these
sponsorships and this individual we were
putting all into you know making the
film and and trying to market the film
we ended up spending more money of our
own and getting a little bit further
into debt so after that film I was in it
I was in a tough place couldn't figure
how to make any money off that film it
just it was just my sophomore slump and
it was a really tough one so moving on
to my third film ride the divide I you
know figuring things out I'm realizing
okay sponsorships man I know I can make
these work better by this time I had two
examples and I could sort of paint
10-yards as a success to the sponsors
when we went out to try to get money so
I worked with Mike Dion on this and we
went out and we actually raised quite a
bit of sponsorship money I'd say I want
to say around 50 grand and then there
was again private investment put into
that film probably equal amount and
private investment so we actually had a
nice chunk of money that was put in that
film because we got closer to release
there was another little bit of
investment that came in to finish it up
and so that film was great because it
was in we were in a situation where
there was always cash but we were very
smart about not overspending cash and
really most of that money is going into
production not really paying people it's
going into travel it's going into you
know the aspects of post-production
where you really need to hire expertise
like sound and color correction and just
finishing the film and getting it really
solid you know being able to buy product
and things like that so you can sell the
film so we had a great situation where
when that film was done it wasn't
too much of that you know money to pay
back there's a little bit I think there
was a little bit of debt still debt
slash investment that was put into that
film and so we were able to pay that off
quickly because the film was was really
successful and had you know miss by far
my but my most most most profitable film
so far that I've worked on and it's you
know continues to do really well and
that that film released three or four
years ago I think about three three and
a half and it's still doing really well
so it's pretty cool because it's like we
passed that mark now it creates a
revenue stream that I try to figure out
ways not to use but you know inevitably
I do at times to make sure I further
further my career I keep reinvesting in
my films so moving on to the fourth film
that was where the yellow stone goes
which was made in tandem with another
film called reveal the path and I have
some ownership in each of those films so
kind of talk about both of those
together essentially where the yellow
stone goes was able to raise about
seventy five thousand in sponsorship
money this is coming from basically
corporate brands or not or nonprofit one
nonprofit for for corporate brands they
put money into the film because they
liked the message that's that told we
found ways to create some ancillary
content and just kind of help you know
use the film to drive at some of the
messages they're trying to communicate
and reach the same audience then we were
also able to raise some crowdfunding
money around the time that film was
finished and ready for market which
helped it go to market we took all the
money we raised some crowdfunding and
put it into pushing the film further out
there and getting more screenings set up
which is scary to do because you're like
you work so hard you're like oh I'm
sudden we got thirty two thousand
dollars in the bank and you're like this
is great it's payday but but we look at
it and we're like it's not you just it's
all askew to keep putting his money in
there one way or another and so that
films done also done really well and it
was nice that the minute it went to
market for the most part I mean it took
a there's a little bit maybe to pay off
for like a month or two but like it was
like basically instant
instant money they were able to give
back to the partners and the creators at
the same time we made reveal the path
which I got it got more investment than
sponsorship it got a little bit of
sponsorship not as much as where the
yellow stone goes I can't say the exact
figure but you know it's less than 75
thousand and but it got also quite a bit
of confusion of investment it was a
highly intensive like travel around the
world film where we went to five
different countries and shot and so
we're dealing with a more expensive film
and where the old stone goes and so in
the end that film went to market and had
a lot of money to pay back and we're
still important paying that film back so
that's just kind of an example of how
you got away all these things and be
careful if you can if you can raise some
money and really be careful about how
you spend that money and then you know
try to get partners creative creative
partners on board who will benefit later
you can get to that that money coming in
quicker and then finally Walter Walter
was is a very low-budget film a lot of
sweat for both my wife and I was it's
kind of a collaborative project where we
came together as we were getting married
and made this film and so we had some
investment about $35,000 in investment
to make the film we use that cash and
then raised 25,000 for its release and
put a lot of sweat and got some some
friends to help us out so we've got our
getting our creative partner strategy
and we're now releasing it with not too
much debt we have some investment but
that's part of the it kind of balances
out with the creative partners as well
so I mean we hope that by next year or
you know early next year depending on
how fast we push the release because
we've been thinking about kind of taking
time but we hope that film is paying
everybody back you know soon so it seems
to be working you know but it's and keep
in mind that Walter actually started
before where the yellow stone goes so it
kind of kind of fits in there and
ultimately where the old stone goes let
has led to
another film a whole River series and
one of the sponsors that was involved
with that doubled their commitment to
the next film and intends to do it a
series of more river films with us so
we're doing sort of the same sort of
strategy where we keep a documentary
that is essentially low cash budget high
sweat budget and in the end has a has a
quicker payout for the people that are
involved that are committed and take the
chance
you